was ist zum beispiel auch ein buch finde
ich etwas was sich wunderbar im regal
macht so nicola hier ein monster monster
monster für dich mitgebracht herrschaft
der dinge die geschichte des konsums von
15 jahrhundert bis heute
ärger hat wahnsinnig faszinierend finde
ich und ich will dir sagen warum ich
glaube dass ganz viele lebensentwürfe
über reklame an leute herangetragen
werden die sonst keinerlei möglichkeit
hätten sich über verschiedene
rollenvorbilder zu informieren wieso
sollte ich tausend seiten sachbuch lesen
über konsum noch dazu da gucke ich mir
doch lieber drei werbungen an und hat
neue rollen aber findest du dich jetzt
dass diese theorien unseren blick auf
konsum wirklich noch erweitern kauf
jetzt zahl später ja das ist die
überschrift von einem kapitel ich
versuche ja zu konsumieren was ich
brauche und nicht noch zusätzlich zu
konsumieren was ich nicht brauche ich
erlebe eine neue nicola du versuchst
über den konsum zu reduzieren und die
ich nur auf das zu beschränken was du
brauchst ich versuche es dass meine
tochter sagt auch immer ich versuche ist
und das ist ja auch wissenschaftlich
erwiesen dass konsum glücksgefühl eben
nicht nachhaltig sondern das einzige was
nachhaltig ist und soziale kontakte
freundliche menschen wie du zeigst du
dabei in meine richtung auf mensch ich
lese lieber einen roman
ich lese lieber henry james alle firmen
sollen bitte schön wenn das alle machen
von henry james ließen
genau darauf einigen wir uns